support and resistance levels are the
key to becoming consistently profitable
at trading I lost money when I first
started out trading not knowing how to
accurately find ones that actually work
versus ones that are more likely to fail
so only shows you the five key Concepts
to finding accurate strong support and
resistance levels so you can
consistently make money while using them
now first off if you are a complete
beginner when it comes to finding
support and resistance levels the whole
idea is that you are trying to find
important areas in the market where it's
essentially likely to bounce either it's
likely to bounce off of the highs and
it's going to push the current Trend
down and shift it or a downtrend comes
to the lows and a potential support area
where it's going to reverse and start an
uptrend and so the whole idea with these
is that if you can accurately find where
the Market's going to likely to turn
down you can enter in a trade and profit
from that move down and then on the flip
side is the same thing is you enter in a
trade at the lows and you can profit
from it going up and so this is a way
that you can make money generally in
more sideways and volatile markets from
either direction you can make money by
going up and you can make money by going
down I only trade reversals and so I
have spent years looking at support and
resistance levels and so these five
concepts are really really important to
accurately finding these levels and so
if you want a cheat sheet to be able to
go back and look at these five key
Concepts I have a PDF that you can
download in the description below it'll
be a great look back reference after you
get this full explanation I'll
definitely explain more in this video
but that is a great resource for you to
use and look back on so the whole idea
with support and resistance levels and a
lot of time is you can call them like
supply and demand just the whole way of
how the market works is it's pushed up
by buyers and then When Buyers dry up it
gets push down and that's more when
sellers take control and so it moves
back and forth with this supply and
demand but you can call them supply and
demand or support and resistance and the
first key concept that I like to use is
instead of drawing a specific line at
say hey the market bounced up here at
this was the high and so I want to see
if it bounces at that exact price again
I'm going to use that as my resistance
level I like to instead use a a zone for
either my resistance levels or my
support levels because just looking at
this chart I have right here you can see
that we're in a nice sideways range here
but the market is rarely bouncing in the
same spot it bounced kind of here before
it bounced up here twice bounced down
here bounced down here but you see all
of these are really at different exact
levels and so the important thing is is
to treat it more like a a Zone and when
you're trading is say okay you know the
market bounced here previously you know
I'm going to think that it'll probably
come up to this area somewhere up here
and bounce again I don't know where
that's going to be but I want to be
aware of that general area and the
reason why it happens like this is
because when the market comes down to
let's say this support level and it's
already bounced here multiple times but
it's you know bounced in different areas
and so that's why you know Drew Zone
based on that the market can have
different factors when it comes into
this level and so when it's selling off
into this area it's going to either have
buyers that come in earlier and push the
price higher sooner because they say hey
I see that it's coming down to this
previous level and so I think it's
stronger this time and it's more likely
to bounce sooner and so I want to get in
earlier because the Market's stronger
this time or on the flip side it can go
further down to the you know more bottom
of your range and it can bounce there
and again it's just based on when the
buyers really start to come in and
overtake the sellers changing and
pushing the pressure of the market
higher and so you can see how drawing
and treating it like zones is way more
important and accurate as these develop
over time you can see here it kind of
bounced here in this exact spot twice it
bounced a little higher this time and
other times you'll see like on this side
is it broke out of where this previous
high was and so it'll have times where
it barely hits your zone or it breaks
out of your Zone and I like to call
these a failed breakout and so they'll
jump in here betting that the Market's
going to go higher and they'll think
okay well it broke that high I've made a
good chunk and then they'll look and see
okay well it it's now breaking this high
back here as well and instead if they
you know jump in Long there they'll get
trapped because the market will instead
reverse back down and so that's why even
if it breaks out of your zone or it
doesn't quite touch your Zone here it
can still technically reverse zones are
extremely subjective and how I usually
like to draw them is I like to take in
account the extreme high and then a lot
of either kind of the chop area and to
zoom in on this a little bit this
support Zone actually might be a little
easier just because you can see it will
it bounc here it bounced here and it
bounced here and this is kind of if you
think about it one major swing here and
so I like to count the extreme of that
swing and then just any other kind of
chop of that area where it before you
know it started to take off and so up
here you know kind of this Zone I see it
as well the market kind of took off here
found a high and then reversed and once
it kind of hit here it just kind of
really gave that back up and so I think
it's good to take in those account that
but again just because that's where your
zone is don't just think exactly at okay
if it touches my zone it's going to
reverse or you know if it breaks the
Zone it's not going to reverse anymore
because things can happen where it'll
hit this area and then reverse and it
didn't really hit your Zone but in
reality it kind of hit this area up here
and it still kind of hit this chop area
where the market started to slow right
and so when you're looking for reversal
zones you have to kind of have that
broader bigger mindset of it can reverse
in either of these areas in terms of you
know right before the zone or breaking
out the other side of the zone and so
the next important thing is focusing on
those extremes if you look at you know
all the price movement in this chart the
Market's bouncing back and forth all
over the place you know it's it's
finding a resist little micro resistance
here it's finding a micro support here
before it you know changes where it's
going and so what you can do is if
you're thinking about well made a little
reversal here and here and so maybe I
should draw a Zone here maybe there
maybe here as well what about here
because it bounced here you know it
starts to add a ton of these more micro
levels that cloud your judgment and just
put too much on the chart when it comes
to trading focusing on a few key things
is the key to success making it as
simple as possible and when it comes to
reversal trading you want to be trading
when the market is
overextended and when it becomes
overextended is way more likely at these
extreme levels where I am drawing these
zones off of because when it comes back
down to this area well you've already
seen it bounce here so that's a good
confirmation but also in terms of just
the overall trend is it's got movement
in here and most of the time things will
be more choppy in the middle of a range
if it's in a range but you can see it it
has a move and then it makes one more
attempt to go lower here and that can be
it overextending and OV exhausting
itself and a lot of the times those are
kind of my best trades when the market
does that it'll snap back to where it
was and right here is a great example of
this look at this move it it pushes up
really far here and all the way up here
here is it looks really strong my
candlesticks I've changed the colors but
you know white is a bullish Candlestick
and so this looks really strong it's
just going up up up up up and up but
because it's kind of one directional
It's actually an unhealthy Trend and we
know that it's kind of getting to an
area where it's revers before and it's
overextended and so it makes it more
likely to reverse and kind of snap back
from that area and you can take a good
reversal trade off of that now of course
you don't know that anything's going to
reverse of these levels right these
levels eventually break you know if you
zoom through the market here you know it
eventually blew out through this level
and you know you move on and you draw
new levels but the biggest thing that
you're trying to do is going forward in
trading is when you see levels like this
and you know multiple bounces here you
can say okay well it's going to come
back here and I can take an accurate
high percentage bet that it's going to
reverse here and that's all you're
looking to do when it comes to reversal
trading and using support and resistance
levels that there is a high percentage
chance that the market reverses at one
of them and to increase that accuracy is
sticking to the extreme levels and
staying away from the chop in the middle
of the range because it's just going to
lose you money in the long run and so
how I like to confirm my levels is I
don't just do it off of one swing
because the market have one swing and
then it could break that swing because
it's in some kind of uptrend and so what
I like to see is I like to see multiple
bounces in that area or major swings off
of that area and so to confirm kind of
this lower level and support level here
honestly I would be looking at this
swing right here and kind of this swing
right here you know I did earlier kind
of say this is kind of one major swing
but before that all develops if you
really look at this the price ni
movement of this was a big swing and so
I think in terms of there's a nice
little double bounce here and then this
is kind of one swing because it doesn't
really rebound here I wouldn't I would
say this is all kind of part of one
bottom and then it starts to make a
higher high here and then it breaks out
and so after that once it kind of pushes
to the other end all I'm doing is I'm
looking at this and saying okay I'm
going to draw My Level here and I'm
going to say once it comes down to this
area area I'm going to expect it to
bounce and that's where the just the
patience part of trading comes in is
you're just waiting for the market to
come to that level all I'm doing is just
sitting waiting to see it come to this
level and I'm just slowly extending it
to the side and so when it comes to this
area that's when I would look to take a
reversal trade off of that and that's
the biggest thing about this is with
these levels as well is you can get
amazing risk reward off of them is you
risk you know a smaller amount of you
know it starts to bottom here starts to
slow and so you jump in here betting
that the Market's going to go up you put
your stop loss down here you know cuz if
you're wrong you just want to get out
and if you're right well the market can
work out in your favor in a big way and
you can make three four five times your
risk in terms of profit and so that's
why I find reversal trading way more
profitable than trying to go for smaller
Contin uation trades or scalps and so
that's a big key for confirming these
levels is looking for two clear swings
now this one up higher would be kind of
a little more difficult because you have
a swing up here and you do have a swing
right here but they are not super close
like this is this is a pretty wide range
in terms of the size compared to this
larger range that we're looking into and
so it would be a little harder to
confirm that and necessarily trade but I
think in terms of if you are using it
especially because this kind of comes
into play as well I think it is a pretty
solid spot but you want to be careful
about again when it's so wide because
when the Market's coming up to this
level remember just because it hits this
Zone doesn't mean it's just immediately
going to reverse you want to use a
checklist or a trading strategy of
reasons to get in right and that's not
something I'm going to explain in this
video I have a ton of other videos on on
that that you can check out but once it
kind of gets into this level that's when
I start looking at that checklist of
saying okay when is it showing up what
is it looking like and then when that
checklist shows up I will jump in and
you know I don't know if it showed up
here but if it did I would potentially
get in on a short and catch that swing
down and then it comes back down to this
area again you look for your trading
strategy checklist to get in on a trade
here and boom you take a potential trade
back up and so that's how I like to use
these support resistance zones for
trading now the fourth key thing to
finding strong support or resistance
levels is the velocity that the market
sells off from an area and so what I
mean by that is if you look at this move
right here the market sold off extremely
fast there's what two candlesticks here
where the market made a massive Move
versus you know here with this move it
it takes you know 10 candles or
something and so what that does is that
shows you there is a ton of selling
pressure at that area where it kind of
started and so for the Zone I like to
think of it well okay when it comes back
up to that area where that massive
selling pressure was it's more likely
that it is going to reverse and same
thing with this guy right here there's a
ton of movement here and same thing on
the flip side a ton of movement there
and so I think it's more likely that
when the market comes back down this
area again it's likely to reverse
because there was that strong buy
pressure off of that level it shows even
more that that was oversold in this case
and the Mark was unbalanced and needed
to snap back to an area and sometimes
you'll have it like this where the
market snaps One Direction it gets over
spot in this case and then snaps back
down as well and so you know going
forwards it still sold off once it got
to that area and going back and forth it
will kind of start to use up that
oversold and overbought but again with
this spot right here where it got even
more overbought that's probably why it
had to break out even more this time is
because it had already kind of balanced
itself after this kind of Swing the
previous kind of day and so then it came
in and overe exhausted itself on this
side and had more of a snapb but you can
see it wasn't as big of a snap back
after that now the last probably most
important one is what time frame you are
drawing your zones off of I use multiple
time frames and drawing my support or
resistance zones or supply and demand
zones off of a larger time frame than
what I trade is extremely important
because what this does is this gives you
a larger picture what we're looking at
right now is actually a 5minute chart
and I will use also a 15-minute chart as
well because what these do is they give
you a bigger picture of what is going on
you can easily see okay here is the
clear range that we're in and you know
where is the big picture of the market
you know you can see going back and
forth is okay here are the extremes and
these are the areas I want to trade off
of and so as the market moves forward in
time you can easily and accurately find
those areas and then what they do as
well is it increases the likelihood that
you're at an extreme and it's going to
reverse so I found that doing this
increases the likelihood that your
trades will work out and then once I
find those levels I go into something
like a smaller time frame chart I look
at a 1 minute chart and then you can see
okay here is where the market comes down
to this level an extreme and I can look
for my multi-step checklist of reasons
of when you know okay I see this I see
this I see this I'm going to buy here
and I'm going to bet the market goes up
and I'm going to catch a swing higher
off of of that extreme support level so
let me walk you through now a strategy
of this in action in real time showing
you how I find these reversals off these
larger levels so every day I go in and I
look for those five key things for
drawing my levels and then I'll go to a
smaller time frame chart I like to day
trade but you can use this on any
marketer time frame really but always
use a larger time frame to draw your
levels and then go into a smaller time
frame to actually enter in your trade
that's going to be way more accurate for
you and so what I do is I look for a few
key steps and look for reversal trades
off of this now again if you want that
PDF of those five Concepts we just went
over to summarize that and easily go
back and look you can get that in the
description below the video now the
biggest key to looking for these
reversals is always approaching it as
what is the market telling me in terms
of it reversing now this is a good
example of a trade on a small account
I'm kind of doing a small account
challenge right now and this is on a
small account and so I am risking $100
here betting that the market is going to
reverse off of this resistance level
that I've drawn and then you know
betting it to go probably kind of down
here and we'll talk about targets and
why that's a good Target later but if it
gets down there that's a good two three
times my risk and on a small account
risking $100 that is a nice profit and
so the first thing that I'm looking for
obviously is that it comes up to that
level first right that is the number one
key thing to make reversal trading work
is the patience to just wait for the
market to come to an extreme and key
level you can even see the market came
here and reversed off of this little
area right here you can say well you
know it bounced here it bounced here it
bounced here and so maybe it bounces
here maybe I should have got that you
know maybe you even look at hindsight
and say oh I'll try and get that next
time but those don't work very often and
they're more likely to cause you to lose
money in the long run it's better to
just sit out kill that noise and wait
for the market to come to these extremes
and then when it's oversold or
overbought in this case you can capture
on that strong reversal to the downside
and so the first key that I like to use
is after it's kind of hit that level
again you can see it's not quite in my
zone but again it's so close it's good
enough the first thing is is making sure
that uptrend is broken because when
you're counter Trend trading you don't
want to go against a trend because you
know it might come up to a level here
but it's in an uptrend and it's just
going to keep going right we don't know
these these levels aren't going to hold
every time it's not just blindly sell or
buy at these levels and so that's kind
of why I have this uptrend here is you
can see that we had strong bullish
candlesticks here and then it it kind of
started to break is it had a dogee here
it had a bearish candle here here and
then it made kind of another push higher
and so for me that's good enough to say
hey yeah this strong kind of micro Trend
right here is broken and you can see the
Market's kind of being quick with its
reversals and so I'm okay with thinking
that that's a a good enough Trend break
certain kind of Trends they'll need
something else but in this case for this
kind of very one directional unhealthy
Trend it's good in terms of clearing
that kind of need for a reversal break
and so after that my next key that I
like to look for is kind of a reversal
pattern or reversal Candlestick pattern
and so in this case the market started
to show some weakness here with this
kind of dogee here and this kind of red
bar and it broke that up Trend and then
it made these two candlesticks here
these bullish candlesticks breaking this
previous high this high right here
became a new one and for me that said
okay it's still going higher but as soon
as this big bearish candle stick form
right here this big red one that to me
is showing it almost made a a micro
failed breakout it made that kind of
trap where it attempted to make a new
high and it it did it made us a new high
but barely at all you know it didn't
make much before this big bearish
Candlestick came in and so if I kind of
Zoom back in the recording and kind of
show you that in real time right now to
speed this up a little once this
Candlestick finishes forming I think
that's a a good signal for me and I want
to get in right there at the low of that
candle so my thought is okay I want to
get in when it kind of breaks the low of
this candle because to me that's a
strong enough signal that it's likely
going to reverse there and so you can
see initially it kind of starts to go
against me and doesn't look great
initially but you know that's where when
things reverse sometimes they take a
little while the market won't always
just reverse on a dime A lot of times
it'll come up like it did kind of start
to settle down and slow and lose some of
that momentum and strength and then it
will give it back up and start going and
so that's what I'm kind of looking for
and so for once I entered in there I
moved my stop Above This High because
the whole idea is if it comes up here
and knocks me out you know I'm looking
for that kind of quick reversal to fail
and I think if it comes up here comes
back down and and keeps going higher I
think that's a stronger uptrend it's had
a healthy pullback if it does that and
then it keeps going higher and you know
I I want to get out the idea is with
trading is you take your stabs they
either work out really quickly and
really well right away or they just
don't work out and you move on if you're
trying to force a trade in conditions
where it's just not great and not
working out you're going to lose money
if you try and enter in the market over
and over and so once I kind of got going
in my favor here and again this is on a
small account I think I'm risking it
honestly might be like $80 or $90 not
even 100 but the idea is I move my stop
loss here to break even because well if
you look at where we're at here we had a
news this was just a news announcement
I'm trading the NASDAQ futures here
again you can kind of trade this on
anything you want because you're just
reading the candlesticks but there was
kind of a news announcement that made a
big spike right here and then from there
we've been in kind of this choppy range
and so My worry is here is I do think we
can reverse off of here and push back
down and kind of push back to here we'll
talk about that in a second but I'm
looking for you know that to reverse
right I don't want to lose money if
instead the Market's just going to be in
this mode where it kind of just sits
here and goes in a sideways chop I'm
looking for kind of a little bit larger
of a move where I you know risk a small
amount and make a large amount and so
when it kind of had this initial move
right here and it could have reversed
right here off that big green candle and
I would like to get out at break even at
that point and so you know once it kind
of did that I moved to break even and
instead it kind of just had a little
pullback which is good actually in terms
of the health of this move down and then
from there once it starts to kind of
make a new low I actually moved my stop
loss down here again to again capture
some of those profits because I'm
thinking that this Market is pretty
tight I think it's more likely that it
kind of whips back and forth and I'd
rather get out with a small decent size
little one times my risk maybe one and a
half times my risk win versus leaving it
here and you know hoping a home run
happens because those do happen and I
catch those but you have to pick your SP
thoughts right you don't always want to
be managing the same way with your
trades and so here you can see that I've
actually drawn a downtrend line here and
I think that's a really nice way to
manage T because it looks like it's
starting kind of to be in this little
downtrend and the second thing is well
we're getting close to this area now
this isn't a major support level it's
not something I have on a larger time
frame that's why there's not really a
Zone drawing there this is where you
want to use as smaller targets for your
trades though because especially in a
market like this where I don't think
it's going to be a home run I think it's
more likely to bounce and reverse off of
a micro support resistance level now I'm
not necessarily taking my bets and
trades off of those levels but in terms
of if I think the Market's going to be
pretty tight today and I want to just
capture a nice little swing like this
and then get out at at a nice profit I'm
okay using that and a lot of the times
when the market has a big move like this
kind of like we were talking about
earlier that it's a big area where the
market velocity off that area was really
big it's more likely that when the
market comes back down there it's going
to find a bounce and it's going to find
some buyers and support and this trade
right here is going to dry up and slow
down and I want to capture my profits
here because I'm getting you know about
two 2 and 1 half times my risk on this
trade and that is a great trade to just
consistently make money and grow your
trading account and again that's what
you want to start out with you don't
want to be trying to get home runs make
it ton of money make your small account
grow over time and then this you can 10x
this size I have trades on my channel
where this trade would be ,000 and it's
the exact same setup and so actually at
that point you can see I had my stop-
loss down there because I was managing
it pretty tight because we got down in
this other area and it closed out there
and it actually started to reverse and
you can see it started to reverse off
that level now don't forget about that
PDF of the five key Concepts in the
description of this video and if you
want to learn how a trade like I do you
need to learn how Futures work Futures
are the best instrument I think for
learning and growing a small account I
tried options everything before that
before I actually switched to trading
Futures and they worked out way better
it's way simpler and The Leverage is
there just like everything else and it
doesn't gouge you with fees and stuff
like Forex does and so I would highly
recommend learning how to trade Futures
and you can find everything about that
in this video right here